und dann haben wir eigentlich schon
direkt wieder unseren rutscher email den
ging schneller als gedacht ich meine mit
drei minuten dafür gebraucht wird ihr
netz kaputt geht aber nee das ist hier
auch relativ gut dran
hey zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge vom mega projekt ich
wünsch wohin schon auf die falsche
server ip gegangen weil damit eine neue
server ip und ja wohl alles meinte hey
wie candy ip megaprojekt mittelpunkt net
könnte jetzt gerne drauf gehen ist nicht
unser service andere server
deswegen haben wir hier die ip jetzt mal
versteckt bleibt mal wenn wir darauf
gegen 05 50 leute sind drauf
ich hab mich schon gewundert hätten den
krieg ich hab gar keine items naja jetzt
sind wir hier drauf ich wollte erst mal
ganz kurz ein jetpack klar ich brauche
noch mein brauchen solar helm simon
ich brauche immer noch so ein paar
sachen halt von simon weil ich halt
jetzt auch eine zeit lang nicht mehr
hier darauf beziehen wir sie eine zeit
lang war sie man einfach nicht mehr und
deswegen konnte ich nicht mit simon
sprechen allerdings was ich mir gedacht
habe was jetzt erst mal mache sind erst
mal drücken und zwar mache ich mir der
sinn die sandy bridge genau die hier
mitmachen
dafür brauche ich ziegel und sand sehr
onic hat der mir hat er mir leben
gegeben bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher
nur im schwarz vorbei sonst würde ich
auf die suche nach leben gehen es ist
übrigens gerade 20 vor zwölf und ich
müsste eigentlich macht endlich schlaf
nachholen
allerdings wenn ich einfach ich bin
überhaupt nicht mehr reden
deswegen lassen wir das mal lieber sonst
wenn das nicht klappen würde will ich
wirklich netter gehen und irgendwie ja
ich hab ich kein leben sonst gleicher
rate der einzigen server bin gehe ich
kurzen runde knacken und danach gehen
wir ein bisschen romtreuen ihr bisschen
was suchen expedition habe ich wohnte
feier übrigens ex gewesen noch habe den
was ich erst mal hier
da muss der 1 okay da gibt noch die
blöcke das ist gut für irgendwie dann
griffel abbauen oder so wir sind noch
ärzte dann hat die kann ich jetzt auch
in meine sachen packen einfach fällt mir
grad so ein kompressor 8mm skater ist er
weg hier kommt man sitzen jetzt ist man
made in wien statt ihn mit dem anders
aufnehmen dann kümmere ich mich um leben
und ziegel carry trade finance einfach
misrata an sich ist ja jetzt als retter
drei feuerstein zwei pflastersteine und
das wo alle gemacht haben luca du bist
so ein kack doch einfach den kies in den
krater
dafür brauche ich erst recht bekannt
dass er mich dass ein extrakt attacke
kommt gar nichts raus naja kommt gar
nichts raus und den kompressor der
comics raus kommt gar nichts raus
hab ich eigentlich nur ein generator an
die habe ich nicht bringen danke an die
leute die mir hier tutorials gemacht
haben das habe ich jetzt auch aus
gefunden mf ist auf jeden fall schon mal
heftige am aufladen also der pakt 128 eu
pro also prozess ist gerade 20 vor zwölf
ich schon gesagt habe und die ich nehme
also
was soll ich machen keys ich muss jetzt
nämlich drei feuersteine kriegen
ich hab noch vorstände glaube ich habe
ich bin schon da muss ich natürlich
freunde aber hier so ein bisschen kita
abbauen kann nie schaden kann hat schon
wieder raus übrigens meinen viele dass
mir mein text speck installieren soll er
googelt doch einfach mal die texte packs
gut wenn er das gemacht hat dann jetzt
habe ich wieder zuviel feuersteine dann
schreibt man einfach welches ihr davon
haben wollt also welches sich reinpacken
soll ich wird das dann von euch abhängig
machen zwei pflastersteine menschen
würde ich wohl nie wieder auftreiben
können hier electronics circuit hab ich
glaub ich sogar hier noch drin da und
maschinen blog ist einfach wie viel mehr
fällt mir gerade ein mofa-fahrer damit
soll dann machst du bei mir wieder ein
bisschen ach komm ich brauche er nachher
so viel wie feiern
ok jetzt einfach im kreis legen das ist
natürlich schön dass ich jetzt hier so
ein projekt table habt das heißt wenn
ich nicht mehr verbaut kommen die items
bzw
das heißt sie kommen die die alten
company bleiben einfach da drin so
irgendwie hat viel zu lange stehen und
es werde nie wieder kommentare kommen
meine mutter schreit mir wollen wir
durch zu zweit wirken ja meine eltern
wecken mich immer noch dass es nicht
weil ich irgendwie mit becker nicht
klarkommen sondern es ganz einfach aus
dem grund weil ich mit wecker nicht klar
komme ja ich hab dem wetter gehabt mit
zeit lang und dann irgendwann weil meine
eltern dann halt nicht daran halten dann
luca heute können sie kontrollieren ob
die schule macht ist oder nicht und ich
würde natürlich nicht wach das ist luca
den luca kennt ihr wahrscheinlich den
trotteligen drucker advents maschinen
block noch maschinen blog haye ist
erwarte ich mir gleich mehrere man
gleich 33 maschinen gut dann gibt mir
das noch
carbon platten acht davon habe ich das
27 jahre gut habe ich 720 von läuft und
läuft
und dann haben wir endlich schon direkt
wieder unseren rotary major der ging
schneller als gedacht ich meine mit drei
minuten dafür gebraucht leute der nets
kaputt geht
aber der rest ist hier auch relativ gut
dran wie vor akut freunde wir sind
richtig gutes team zusammen er wir
sollten wir öfter zusammen aufnehmen da
hab ich einfach schalter kaplan noch
induction ich hab' ich habe noch ein
induction fürs alter ich bin zu tun habe
ich mir mal zwei gemacht lol lol der
geht hoch wie sonst was klassisch heiße
ja alter massaker cool
wieso 29 entfernt ist ja ich weiß ich
hab noch generell relativ viele technik
gegeben
maschinen blog hab ich mir jetzt vier
gemacht auch gut mit neuen coach aber
euch allerdings anders und obsidian
waren ich brauche auf jeden fall
goldmann irgendwann gold brauche ich
definitiv weil die cores auf ach so das
geht gar nicht
wie k s auf diamanten machen mit mini um
stein genau und die mini umsteigen kann
ich glaube ich auch aufladen wieder grip
wtd kann ich doch nicht
er kann nicht er hat eine haltbarkeit
deswegen kann ich dann irgendwie nur
manchmal verwenden allerdings ist die
haltbarkeit bei dem relativ hoch ich
habe auch noch drei diamanten das heißt
eine neue spitzhacke könnt ich mir
machen allerdings ich bekomme das ja
alles von simon mit wegen warte ich
darauf man so fackel nämlich noch
erstmal mit ich glaub ich hatte gar
keine mehr
aber diese lohnstopp teile die sich auch
gut also die kann ich an sand glaube ich
an bringen sagt er wo kann ich dann an
bringen und schnappt sich die dann
mitgenommen unnötig als dass sie drin
als unnötig ist passiert erstmal raus
lamberts das ja das war's warum ist
seine halterin bitte warum tötet mal mit
bio drin fragt mich nicht aus welchem
film video blabla das ist habe ich mir
ausgedacht das fragen mich immer mehr
die frage
der epische abschluss zum ende der
karwoche das so gar nicht gesehen durch
die folge jetzt freut euch ein bisschen
twain
na gut das funktioniert das könnt ihr
durch
ja okay wenn ich jetzt zu der meinigen
turtle gehe
ach ja ich konnte ja keiner dings machen
weil ich keine kohle habe allerdings
fällt mir ein dass ich einfach das
verbrennen könnte mit sticks ja damit
wir nach so ich brauche gar kein break
mehr fällt mir jetzt auch gerade ein
ich bin so klug der goltz nicht brauche
rohrteile die ich verbrennen kann
das hat wiederum doof silva wird lockt
die mächtig verwurstet möchte ich schon
lieber
ich brauche einfach nur fackeln und
dafür verbrenne ich aber mein gott da
kriegt tropenholz raus das kriegt dann
auswendig tropenholz verbrennen
nach holzkohle das gut dich gibt es hier
gute ware sondern habe ich erstmal 690
fackeln das müsste reichen und ein
bisschen zurecht zu kommen
du bist das ist bestimmt auch wieder
free hier naja ok just dann kommt
erstmal ne menge eisen rein
ich überleg erstmalig brauche auf jeden
fall noch lava zelt um die meinigen
turtelt ein bisschen aufzufüllen ich
glaube ich muss die mannschaft noch
offene ganz tiefe gegebene erst mal
drauf packen ist gar nicht lange ich
darauf nehmen dass es relativ spät
abends und morgens in dieser tag und ich
brauche endlich schlaf blabla aber
nachher müssen wir schauen
ich glaube ich nehme nur eine folge auf
deswegen ich sie gar auch relativ durch
so ich gehe aber nur zwei läufer cells
mehr kriegt ihn nicht gekriegt mehr
die sommer so viele die so die lediglich
0 2
ich brauche was zu fressen ich bin
vorbereitet wie sonst was prepared ich
fahre ski das immer noch nicht für
diesen hunger
was bedeutet das wenn ich jetzt hunger
habe ich war nicht ganz sprinten mein
leben geht nicht runter stehen nie waren
also den das kann ich daran was ist wenn
ich jetzt entlasten und den ja okay das
ist egal die sind unabhängig voneinander
so hier unten
die levels 2000
warum schildchen blog so
komm zu mir du bist jetzt ab hier ab
hier ist eine kiste und ab da oh
verdammt scheiße hätte ich mal man hätte
ich mal nicht vorher die lava zellen dar
eingepackt egal amazon kann man ja kann
man nicht wieder verwenden klasse ich
brauche definitiv nur unendliche lava
quelle schreibt mir auch mal in die
kommentare
ob man sich irgendwie eine unendliche
lava quelle machen kann links war ich
auch noch mit einem steckplatz allen
unten drin ich habe sie mal die ganzen
item schon geschrieben allerdings
antwortet mir sie noch nicht deswegen
spam bitte simon zu dass die items
zurückgeben soll
der antwortet mir einfach nicht ich weiß
ich habe das jetzt irgendwie extra macht
oder so und ob er einfach keine eier hat
oder so beantwortet nicht das finde ich
schon sehr sie von dem dass ihr mich
umbringen was natürlich legal ist ein
gewissen vorn allerdings einfach übel
sozial und auch die rolle gegenüber weil
die natürlich richtig investiert haben
diese rettungsaktion so klappt das denn
jetzt
ich versuche es mal hier so ein bisschen
golf klasse da fallen die items erst mal
1000 jahre hier runter
so waren wir noch was da oben haben wir
noch was ja
so geht das natürlich stimmt dann ist
das gut so ein bisschen smaragde das ist
glaube ich dieser komische rubin
wenn so ein paar wege bahnen einfach mit
dem expert dingsbums
und damit im ganz was ist das okay gut
ich sage dass wir dieses komische liegt
jemand kein stück braucht etwas das ich
weiß nicht was das ist
ziel war ja selber weil sie auch noch
nicht was ich mit silber soll
dort könnt ihr mir übrigens auch alles
in die kommentare schreiben da ist genug
platz da kann jeder was rein schreiben
da brauchte ich jetzt mein herr über
mehr da schon geschrieben da brauche ich
das nicht mehr schreiben von jeder ist
die chance natürlich auch größer dass
ich dann einzelne sachen ein gerne
wieder hinterm rackern ihr euch ob die
kamera kann ich das jetzt eigentlich
abrufe habe ich denn die meinungen
könnte ich weiß da unten war noch was
allerdings noch einiger dollar
die wird das schon noch erledigen du
machst das stark ich freue mich an klaus
jürgen jakob keller
juhu stein kann das relativ schnell
abbauen aber kohle nicht so so ein
bisschen ähnlich die spitzhacke sofort
von der power of fucking berg wo ich gar
nichts getan
mann
ok ich flieg weg ihr habt hilfe gewollt
okay die greb weiter und ich verbiege
mich wohl hier können wir heute ein
bisschen länger aufnehmen
und ich habe nicht mal schwer dabei
simon ich hoffe die stadt das nicht aber
ich gehe mal kurz bei dir wie kommen die
kripo überhaupt auf mein grundstück das
über halfar köln an
und übrigens der onyx grundstück so
verdammt noch mal scheiße aus das ist so
unnormal wenn jemand nicht bauen können
dann ist er ohne hat mich irgendwer hier
im bettchen für mich vielleicht das
gefängnis gefängnis damit nicht einmal
runter da kommt direkt eine spinne
wo ist der krieg bist du da verdammt
weg mit dir du kleine stinktier ich gebe
dir wie einem stier ab morgen in den
tschad your [ __ ] is yours weightman sie
fit bist du langsam hier fertig ist dann
kommst du erst da rein und du auch an
ehe geht nicht die kommt heraus
hier kommt ein schneller propeller
aber ich finde es gut dass es jetzt
wieder läuft also nach meinem verlust
der ganzen sachen durch simon dass wir
da habe ich zwei und aktienfonds keine
ahnung
alles funktioniert hier mit verkabelt
preisgeld wird wünschen noch mitmachen
ach ja ich kann mir unendlich viele
castings machen weil das läuft alles
über energie und ich habe sehr viel
energie so hier kommt ihren die ganze
aktion fairness wenn ihr jemand
quiksilver ich hab echt keinen plan was
euch mit quiksilver machen dass dort nur
für zaubern gut oder
ich weiß es nicht freunde schreibt mir
simba so schön kann ich da noch
einpacken
im koffer auch die 2 ich verstehe nicht
warum das nicht zu zweit geht
ich meine induction verpackt dafür auch
als kirche wieder ich habe wieder so
viel eisen das ist richtig geil
auch für dich so kommt das warten jetzt
mal ganz kurz
was mache ich denn danach erstmal aus
soja ich kann jetzt mal wieder ein paar
sachen lagern
ich bin ich auch bald voll in der kiste
energie tor bett bringt mir dein idol
da kriegt man das draußen lied ingo auch
aus wird auch verzaubern das hat so gute
eigenschaft so wirbelsturm hier dürfe
kein wirbelsturm notfallplan von pokémon
ja
es sind es jetzt hin und her gut dass
beides da noch raus und dann werde ich
mich an ein was meinten die alle weg ich
soll mit beutel machen kennt is back das
bringt mir den can get back meinten
einige soll ich machen dass ein rucksack
irgendwie fahrten und stock also ich
brauche ich hab gar nicht so viel werden
ich habe einen faden darunter zwei
umhänge hat unglaublich viel
ja das können wir auf jeden fall nicht
machen dann meinen alle taschen in den
rucksack so sagt arbeiter rucksack
sollte ich mir machen
die minenarbeiter abenteurer imker
bergarbeiter
15 25 14 sind jemand kiste eisen wolle
fäden
kiste ich hier gar nicht gedanken
hp setzt an einem faden
es hapert tatsächlich an einem fahrrad
davonfahren drin
christine mitte oben wurde unten wolle
als ein eisen baden baden baden baden
bergarbeiter rucksack ja ach so ich muss
mich jetzt nur im inventar haben oder
ja ich glaube schon und wenn ich jetzt
ja ja killer das sortiert sich daran
kohle zwar nicht aber mir ist es egal
la gomera meinberg wollenberg aber das
ist ja cool solchen rucksack kann ich
auf jeden fall schon mal ein paar mehr
items mit mir dran
handwerker rucksack was kann der alles
mitnehmen
dafür brauche ich leben knochen ist
jetzt auch egal so ich schon mal ganz
kurz was die mining turtle unten macht
und dann machen wir mal wieder ein stopp
weil es bei mir jetzt genau newron ich
brauch mal langsam einschlafen action
ich bin nicht mehr mit der begeisterung
von anfang mit am start
ich würde gern mal schauen was jetzt als
eingesammelt hat allerdings habe ich
keine lust es nicht der kripo dabei
stört die ganzen fackeln sammle ich mir
gleich auch mal ein altes eisen so das
geht jetzt alles meinen bergarbeiter
rucksack oder nicht
so wir sind noch ein paar wertvolle
sachen die ich brauche kohle da hinten
ist kohle kohle kann man echt nie genug
von kriegen
das meinten die anderen hatten sich
schon recht wo ich am anfang noch so
oder so viel kohle und die nehme ich nie
mit mittlerweile mit das wertvollste
neben gold für mich was sogar normalen
minecraft nicht so das match ist er so
mal ganz und gar nicht so ist nicht nur
wo kohle colo colo colo colo colo colo
irgendwie schon witzig nicht unterhöhle
einfach mal mein komplettes grundstück
das wird nachher richtig krass aussehen
ich dachte eigentlich dass wir jetzt
automatisch daran sortiert ab jetzt auch
nicht noch so etwas kann ich da nicht
alles reinpacken
na gut freunde das soll es gewesen sein
das soll es gewesen sein von meiner
seite aus ich packte noch ganz kurz die
ganzen sachen ja ein
ach mensch ist nicht das gelbe vom ei
dieser rucksack
potsdam
kohle ich verstehe das nicht wie ich das
damals so sortiert habe das übrigens
auch schon bald von leider muss ich die
dings kiste mal zu einer besseren kiste
machen
freu mich wird schon mal sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über einen daumen hoch freuen
das zeigt mir dass euch gefallen hat
halt und dass ihr mehr megaprojekt volt
bzw
dass ich mich damit beschäftigen
nächsten folgen wären dann bringen dass
ich erstmal meine mittel kontrolliere
und dann dass ich halt irgendwann von
simon die sachen wieder bekommen und
dann mich wieder in den äther vage um
dann klostern zu erwischen und klaus
donald damit ich mein haus bauen kann
und dafür braucht eine menge kloster
oder brauche ich nicht so viel ich
brauche einfach noch sandy bridge von
und dafür bräuchte leben deswegen muss
ich auf andere warten wir sind dann ist
mal wieder typisch